[Applause]
come on
horror and panic moments after a
drive-by shooting outside a church
a shotgun was fired from a car as
mourners left a memorial service near
Houston injuring six people four women
and two children a 12 year old with
minor injuries and a seven-year-old girl
now in a stable but life-threatening
condition
father Jeremy trude was inside the
church at the time and described scenes
of Chaos it was pandemonium there was
this enormous bang
and people rushed back who were leaving
church then just rushed back into the
church screaming and and saying that
there'd been a
shots fight had been fired
police are still searching for those
behind the attack and trying to trace a
car a black Toyota CHR possibly a 2019
model officers responded with paramedics
and a crew from the London air ambulance
they found multiple people with injuries
caused by pellets from a shotgun
I can promise that we are doing
everything we can to identify and bring
to Justice those who are responsible for
this attack the memorial service was for
a mother and daughter who died within a
month of each other last year
twenty-year-old Sarah Sanchez passed
away from leukemia in November just
weeks after her mother fresia Calderon
died I've spoken to people who attended
the service here on Saturday and while
they didn't want to be identified they
did confirm that those injured in the
shooting were mourners at the Requiem
Mass they described screaming and people
running for cover inside the church but
they also said they didn't understand
why any of this had happened
at the church the cordons lifted and
services resume an attempt to regain a
sense of normality
but for many here disbelief at events
remains I felt I lived to come this
evening to offer our prayers for that
those injured in the shooting and also
for the perpetrators
done up described as a senseless act of
violence people are now left trying to
Fathom why this ever happened on their
streets outside a place of Refuge Adele
Robinson Sky News